realmente me gustó esta imagen que
encontré de hecho
enseña muy bien y muy bonito donde se
encuentra situado el corazón de nuestro
cuerpo así que puedes ver que el corazón
está rodeado por ambos lados por
costillas verdad y de hecho no lo he
dibujado aún pero déjenme mostrarles
dónde se encontrarían los pulmones
se encuentran
de este lado el corazón se encuentra
justo en medio de dos pulmones y estoy
diciendo que este es el pulmón
izquierdo perdón es el pulmón izquierdo
y este es el pulmón derecho ok y lo
estamos diciendo izquierdo y derecho
justo desde la perspectiva de la persona
que tiene este corazón así que si este
es el lado derecho para esta persona y
el lado izquierdo para esta persona que
es el opuesto para nosotros y lo estamos
viendo de frente
ahora el corazón de hecho está situado
entre estos dos pulmones y hay dentro de
ésta digamos carcasa protectora que son
las costillas y que básicamente están
ahí para cuidar todos estos órganos
importantes y debajo de ellos se
encuentra un músculo también igual de
importante digo esto no es un músculo
del cual la gente se la pase hablando no
es
un músculo del cual la gente vaya al
gimnasio para para trabajarlo pero es un
músculo muy importante y este músculo es
llamado el diafragma
este es el diafragma así que tus
costillas están encerrando cierto
espacio
el diafragma sería como el suelo de este
de este espacio y las costillas son una
especie de techo o las paredes de este
espacio así que vemos si vemos este
espacio que tenemos aquí todo esté
definido por las costillas y por el
diafragma donde tenemos los pulmones y
el corazón el corazón perdón todo este
espacio es llamado el tórax
el tórax
así que es lo que exactamente hace el
corazón déjenme hacer un poquito de
espacio aquí y vamos a traer una versión
digamos más
cercana de lo que es el corazón así que
déjenme empezar orientándoles dónde está
el corazón digamos aquí está el pulmón
derecho y aquí está el pulmón izquierdo
y todo esto estaría dentro de nuestra
caja de costillas la caja torácica pero
no voy a dibujarla ahora porque eso
haría muy difícil de ver lo que es el
corazón así que piensen exactamente qué
es lo que puede hacer el corazón y una
forma muy bonita de hacerlo es imaginar
que ustedes son una linda y agradable
célula que ustedes son esta linda y
agradable célula así que si se ponen
ustedes en la perspectiva de una célula
digamos que ahí están simplemente
colgando por ahí y este esta célula vas
a hacer tú y puedes pensar en cualquier
parte del cuerpo que te gustaría hacer
digamos que este es una célula de pie
célula de pie
de algún dedo del pie digamos y tu
trabajo por supuesto es solo vivir y ser
feliz y tienes por aquí cerca por aquí
cerca tienes una un vaso sanguíneo
aquí está cerca un vaso sanguíneo y
nuestra célula de pie de aquí está
tratando de hacer su vida así que qué es
lo que necesitan las células de pie
necesitan ciertas cosas por ejemplo
necesitan oxígeno aunque vamos a notar
eso necesitamos oxígeno para esta célula
de pie y además de eso necesitan también
nutrientes verdad nutrientes
así que las células necesitan ciertas
cosas para vivir y por el otro lado
también generan después desechos de
desperdicios o desechos desechos ok que
pueden ser muchísimas cosas podrían ser
por ejemplo lo que se me viene a la
mente es dióxido de carbono vamos a
considerar el dióxido de carbono como el
desecho de estas células
muy bien entonces esta está haciendo
algunos desperdicios por el momento
vamos a pensar que no hay flujo en este
en este vaso
si influjo
que en este vaso sanguíneo que está
cerca no hay flujo así que esta pequeña
célula al estar generando desperdicios
vamos a ir dibujando bolitas que son
desperdicios todo este espacio se
empieza a llenar cada vez más y más y
más de estos desperdicios así que poco a
poco las células se empieza a llenar o
se empieza digamos a empantanar de sus
propios desperdicios y podrías pensar
que esto se empieza a llenar
completamente se empieza a cubrir por su
propio desperdicio y por el otro lado
necesita oxígeno y nutrientes verdad así
que si no hay flujo no va a obtener
ninguna de estas cosas así que digamos
que en muy pocos minutos nuestras
células va a estar pensando que esta no
es una agradable forma de vivir esto es
lo que esto es realmente muy triste y es
muy malo si esto continúa en la célula
podría morir así que lo que necesita una
célula de pie o de hecho cualquier
célula del cuerpo puede ser de dedo
puede ser de piel o realmente cualquier
célula lo que necesita para vivir es
verdad esta necesita flujo necesitamos
quitar todo esto para que haya un flujo
y ahorita voy a explicar justamente por
qué entonces necesitamos que haya un
escribirlo
que haya flujo y con este flujo vamos a
hacer una imagen muy distinta porque si
hay flujo digamos que tenemos aquí
nuestras bolitas que se están generando
del desperdicio de la célula pero con
flujo este flujo va a arrastrar todas
estas hacia otros lados ok es más o
menos como tener alguien que recoja la
basura si no hay alguien que recoja la
basura entonces toda la casa se va a
llenar de ella así que si tienes un
lindo flujo a cambio también vas a poder
tener la red pues vas a poder recibir
tanto el oxígeno como los nutrientes a
través de este vaso ok
así que todo lo que ocurre en la célula
va a ser ahora no un estado triste no un
estado difícil para vivir sino todo lo
contrario va a estar contenta de vivir
muy bien así que si realmente quieres
cualquier célula en tu cuerpo para que
viva muy bien justo como esta célula de
aquí lo que realmente necesitas es un
buen flujo a través de todo el cuerpo y
ese es el punto número uno que hay que
que hay que tratar ok
realmente necesitamos tener flujo
sanguíneo que esté moviéndose y
empujando con
la sangre a través del cuerpo así que
para que esto ocurra para billones y
billones de células necesitas una muy
bonita y poderosa bomba cierto eso es
algo que va necesitamos algo que sea
capaz de jalar toda la sangre del cuerpo
y después empujarla de vuelta y eso es
lo que el corazón hace ok
digamos su tarea una de sus tareas
centrales es justamente la de funcionar
como una bomba es una bomba maravillosa
que empuja la sangre así que para que
así tengamos un buen flujo sanguíneo así
que voy a escribir su primer tarea su
primer tarea del corazón y es justamente
tener flujo sanguíneo y lo voy a
escribir como flujo sistémico flujo
sistémico y cuando hablo de la palabra
sistémico en realidad estoy pensando o
me estoy refiriendo a todo el cuerpo así
que la palabra sistémico cuando utilizo
esa palabra se refiere a todo el cuerpo
y las células de todo el cuerpo verdad
ahora exactamente cómo es que ocurre
esto
podemos ver en la figura que tenemos
aquí
vena gigante digamos
esta vena
pena gigante y tenemos por aquí una
arteria
una arteria
una arteria entonces esta es una arteria
y la sangre de hecho está yendo a través
de la arteria en esta dirección hacia en
esta
dirección
va a estar ingresando al corazón a
través de estas dos venas esta que vamos
a llamarla esta vena superior que es la
vena cava superior
superior y va a ingresar también a
través digamos de esta que es la vena
vena cava inferior que por supuesto no
la podemos ver porque está del lado
trasero digamos del corazón ok pero hay
ahí es esta vena que es la vena cava
inferior y estas dos venas estas dos
venas está también por supuesto es una
vena están llevando toda la sangre a
través de todo el cuerpo al corazón va
de todo el cuerpo del corazón y después
cuando el corazón está listo para
regresarlo se va a través de esta
arteria cuyo nombre que este es una
arteria cuyo nombre es la aorta que esta
es la arteria de la cual la gente habla
mucho así que esto es como la sangre
entra y sale del corazón pero no es el
único trabajo del corazón
su único trabajo el segundo trabajo del
corazón se refiere
segundo trabajo del corazón se refiere
al flujo pulmonar
flujo
pulmonar
ahora que estamos pensando con eso bueno
sabemos que las células están esperando
oxígeno verdad sabemos esto que tienen
muchísimo dióxido de carbono como
desecho y que por eso es bueno tener
cosas que se estén moviendo alrededor es
decir que tengamos sangre que tenga un
flujo pero de hecho de nada nos sirve
tener un flujo que se lleve el dióxido
de carbono si no hay algo si no hay
oxígeno que esté llegando aquí si una
célula no tiene oxígeno pues tampoco va
a vivir feliz digo puede hablar puede
haber flujo sanguíneo pero hasta cierto
punto necesitamos oxígeno que vaya a
través de ese flujo ok
así que aquí es donde entran en juego
los pulmones aquí es donde entran en
juego los pulmones así que qué ocurre
con el corazón antes de enviar la sangre
a través de la aorta antes de enviarla
de vuelta a todo el cuerpo
de hecho manda sangre a través de los
pulmones manda sangre a través de los
pulmones digamos atrás
a este pulmón izquierdo vamos a ponerlo
manda sangre a este pulmón y luego
también va de regreso lo mismo ocurre
con este pulmón el derecho que manda
sangre de estos pulmones y después
regresan al corazón y después salen
disparados a través de la aorta así que
aquí es donde hay un paso extra donde la
sangre va hacia los pulmones y ese es el
flujo pulmonar así que la última parte
que debes notar son estas estas pequeñas
estos pequeños vasos digamos estos de
aquí que algunos son rojos que por
supuesto esas son arterias y hay otras
azules que esas son las venas verdad
todas éstas serán parte del sistema del
flujo sistémico o del flujo pulmonar o
de alguna otra cosa entonces pensemos
todos estos vasos son llamados vasos
coronarios y voy a agregar el título de
vasos sanguíneos
sanguíneos
vasos sanguíneos coronarios
ok y todos estos vasos sanguíneos
coronarios de hecho sirven para el
músculo del corazón
recordemos que el corazón está hecho por
miles y miles quizás diez miles de
células y todas esas células justo como
nuestra célula del pie que dibujamos de
este lado necesitan oxígeno y nutrientes
y también tienen desechos así que estas
células van a necesitar vasos sanguíneos
que las alimenten muy bien así que esos
son lo que las células perdón los vasos
sanguíneos coronarios son son
literalmente vasos sanguíneos que van y
sirven al corazón ok entonces estos
sirven sirven al corazón
sirven al corazón ahora sí están
sirviendo a los músculos del corazón y
si las células cardíacas
y a las células cardíacas pensemos que
habrían dentro del flujo sistémico o el
flujo pulmonar bueno si el trabajo
principal es atender las necesidades de
las células
entonces los vasos coronarios caen
dentro del flujo pulmonar